what's the most joy you've had as a
writer
the most joy i've had as a writer
is seeing
my work affect
people both at uh a screening
of something i wrote that has been made
into a film and then
also even in a table read
um or even just hearing it after the
fact someone read my screenplay and just
talks about not what's good about it or
what's not working but just where
they responded to um
i think that's when i've
gotten the most joy because i think it's
what we're trying to do i think
as a screenwriter you're trying to
affect someone
and when you can do that
in an honest and real way through
a piece of art that you made i think
you've achieved the goal at least in
terms of
the art and on the flip side the most
pain you've had as a writer
the most pain i've had as a writer
are the days that i
didn't write and i have no good reason
that i didn't write feeling like
i should have i planned to put in the
work today
and i didn't and that's going to
uh set me back simply as a
professional that shows up to do the job
that feels tough
looking at yourself in the mirror and
recognize that
there was there was no nobody holding
you back today except for you
and that feeling is tough
were you always that honest with
yourself like knowing
this is more me than well i had this
deadline to meet
and that's pretty self-reflective it's
um
i think i've always been self-reflective
but not always in i think a very honest
way i think i
was interested in a lot of um self-help
books
and stuff to make me a better person a
better writer a better
whatever but i wasn't actually putting
in the work of like kind of
who i am now and and
how i tick and and what um gets me going
what turns me off all those sort of
things i'd never really done the
self-reflection
required for that i was just kind of
taking a lot in externally but not
really doing the internal
digging and it wasn't until a few years
ago
that i realized that and started doing
that
self-reflection and it's tough i think i
think it's necessary
to be a great artist i think you have to
do that especially if you're putting
yourself out on the page
you have to really understand who you
are
so that you understand what's coming out
and
it's not always the best picture of
yourself the reflection that you see
changes day to day and that has as much
to do with who you are
um inside also who you are in
what you're seeing it's it's it's
perception both
inward and outward and um
sometimes when you see that reflection
and you say
ah that's you know you had no good
reason
to not work today on
your art that you say you love so
what's what's going on and when
i can't really find an answer that feels
satisfactory it's
probably the most pain i feel as a
writer so do you think you you feel like
you've let yourself down
yeah and i think that's really that's
the biggest
letdown is that i have let myself down
and everything else
in relation to that i feel like i can
take in
stride if someone doesn't like my work
if someone
doesn't uh want to produce
my work if someone doesn't want to work
with me
there's always there's always you know
there's someone else
that is involved in that dynamic and so
there's always something there to say
okay well i can do all the
self-reflection i want but
maybe that's just on them there's
something there and like that this just
isn't going to work out like
for whatever reason if i let that person
down if they let me down there's always
someone else but if it's
when it's you letting yourself down
there's no one else to deflect any of
that
feeling towards uh whether that
deflection is right or wrong
and so you just kind of feel it on both
ends i think because you
you let you let someone down yourself
and you are also let down by someone
yourself so it it it can be
a little isolated and lonely and painful
when that happens but it's human i think
we all do that
and so i guess i should remember that as
well
well that goes back to when we started
out the interview which was just
being in la and traffic and then wanting
to arrive on time
especially if you want to be punctual
and sometimes there's just things just
totally
doesn't matter you could have you know
oh a half hour early i'll be fine you
know
and some crazy thing happens and there's
a roadblock and
and going back to you feel like you've
you've let yourself and someone else
down but
it's out of your control kind of thing
yeah so it's when everything
when everything is in your control and
it happens that's when i feel the pain
i keep repeating pain because i feel
like that's that's okay that was the
question
makes you feel it makes it seem more
dramatic but that's when that's when as
a writer it's
uh yeah it's it's it's tough i think
so i mean the way out of that is to show
up and write
so that's what i try to do
you